ne les laissez pas s'enfuir
rendez vous
jamais
gwendoline tu veux bien posé cet
appareil photo wenn domine le dessert
est servie guen c'est moi je suis un peu
le mouton noir de la famille ils me
prennent tous pour une attardée et
malheureusement je me dis parfois qu'ils
ont raison ma pauvre qu elle fait pas
attention à elle
on va mettre en prison ou chez les fous
tu as voyagé dans le temps c'est pas
drôle j'ai peur tape applet américaine
vient avec moi vite il n'y a qu'eux qui
peuvent t'aider
dis leur que j'ai apporté le rubis
g unit
précieuse exceptionnel chaque voyageur
du temps incarne une pierre précieuse
tuer leur vie tous les regards se
tourneront vers toi
gwendoline voici vidéo de villiers vous
ferez équipe
gwendoline n'est pas vraiment mon genre
des calquières la plus forte
le diamant et voici votre carte de
crédit peut tout m'offrir bien sûr vous
êtes le rubis
moi je dois porter tous ces costumes
pour vos missions quelle mission je ne
suis que la costumière
une fois le sens des élus collectés
celui qui possédera le chronographe
pourra libérer son pouvoir rider on a
déjà rapporté six prélèvements du passé
il ne reste plus que quatre à visiter
gwendoline n'est pas prête
elle va me ralentir il va falloir que je
continue tout seul
de cache la vérité le conte sacrifiera
du gt1 c'est clair on
tu ne peux pas échapper
pour être allé